I mean one thing is if I'd been born 400
years ago I my legs were twisted around
I would have been disabled from the
get-go and I probably would have just
had some accident when I was four or
five and would have been dead so
healthcare they put my feet in the cast
for the first six weeks of my life I'm
incredibly nearsighted I'd probably have
even I was born yeah I probably would
have run into a tree by now or fallen
under a horse or something so that to
some extent we're now evolving to be
much less physically fit than even a few
hundred years ago simply because life is
much easier the the real question of
course is how much will we now be making
would amount to eugenic decisions and
that's that's an interesting and scary
thought I've it's happening minutes in
its own way it's happened in China
simply in favor of boys and that's
creating all kinds of social disruptions
because there are too many men and not
enough civilizing women if I can say
that so we're now in many cases weeding
out certain easily testable things that
you can do in amnio testing for
especially in people who have some kind
of family history of Down syndrome or
whatever will we be yeah and there's
even now because in the old days
physical prowess mattered more I think
you didn't have as much kind of
intelligence assortment mating or
something like that so you know we're
already changing how things are evolving
with
using genetic information and it's again
people are going to face more and more
ethical decisions about how much don't
want to control what kind of kid I have
its and that's quite apart from all this
creating new life and stuff like that at
23andme for example I mean again I it's
hard to argue with a statement of fact
that I think is true so what do you do
about that fact well to some extent you
say 11 goal of 23andme is to do various
correlation tests and it's it's not very
useful to have a a very limited
population so what we will do is work
with foundations and other things and
offer free or very cheap tests to
selected populations with a certain
condition like you know Alzheimer's or
whatever and we over time would love for
this stuff to be cheaper and it will be
because the the real cost is in the lab
that's a per-unit cost the cost of our
website and the information goes down
per person as the number of members goes
up so over time this will all get
cheaper most good things are pretty
expensive when they start out and I I
don't think that's immoral what I think
is immoral is when a government doesn't
well what's the most immoral the
government is corrupt and steals from
its citizens but a good government
representing as people will educate them
all and make sure that they have the
education and the capability to be
productive and then they can afford to
take care of themselves and by genetic
tests in the meantime especially in
emerging markets the government also has
to be much more involved in healthcare
and things like that so it's the fact
that things are expensive is not immoral
the fact that people are prevented from
fulfilling their capabilities and are
stolen from by their governments and
cheated and humiliated is what's immoral